hey guys it's a girl
graduated every idea who the father is
30 times guy let's go 3 2 1 this is
doctor David George our mission is to
intercept a research pond from Mars 15
steps to fix the shower I'm an astronaut
not a gym teacher this is the first
capital ever to come back from the
planet we have visual confirmation it
this could be a major scientific
breakthrough Wow cue instagram- case
with lyre and learning oxygen more
carbon dioxide
beautiful and finally a daddy your big
custody battle over this one no we're
gonna keep it up here going to study
we're safe
you can't worry every single to the
muffled oh I don't have to model one
brain how smart is perfect
[Music]
these creatures wiped out math millions
of years ago if we let it get to earth
well we all human life let's kill the
thing good night moon
good night room good night
cow jumping over the moon in the night
in the red blue
what is the primal instinct of any life
form we've lost all communication and
we'll hit the atmosphere in 39 minutes
[Music]
but it could
nice because it's everywhere
[Music]
are you recording
ready let's go watch the new trailer now
at life movie calm
you